on éteint ses téléphones on se met en
rang deux par deux et on ouvre ses
classeurs c'est enfin l'heure du conseil
de classe
et aujourd'hui c'est l'élève bernard ont
quelques y ait demandé au tableau ah bon
je vous le confirme
mais oui mon petit bernard ou plutôt
devrais je dire l'ami des stars du
showbiz à l'elysée tout le monde le
connaît moi je me souviens d'un
demi-millier comment il est ton papa ou
des cas pas de mauvaises moeurs aux
[ __ ]
non moi je suis chaque année j'avais une
sorte de passe droit à l'époque
cherchait des gens ignorent combien on
se demande presque si sa véritable
vocation ne serait pas porte parole du
gouvernement
j'aimerais qu'on écoute un des porte
parole du gouvernement bernard poignant
conseil des ministres qui c'est qui
ramène le café c'est bernard et moi je
bouffe à tous les râteliers récent
boulanger à lui il veut lécher le cul
tout le monde et j'ai bien l'impression
qu'il aime ça c'est possible mais
derrière ce joli minois le petit bernard
n'est pas celui qu'on croit
ne croyez pas tout ce qu'on a eu zéro
pointé en ce qui concerne la discipline
son vocabulaire est clairement à revoir
chez sa grand mère un petit tour sur la
grande librairie ne lui ferait pas de
mal allez plus que quelques mois avant
la fin de l'année on ne lâche rien mon
anar alors bernard montiel
je vais pas vous demander de mettre des
notes c'est pas ça me dit conseil de
classe c'est ce que voulait revenir sur
sur ce que vous avez dit super avons
tiré après ils ont montré ce qu'on dit
ses amis de lui
les tissus md et oui carla bruni
brigitte macro et non c'est énorme
ah oui d'ubs relève non non non non je
vous ai promis que les voix oui on
voulait qu'on voit ce qu'il y ait des
tiges à l'idée de vous alors là bonjour
c'est laeticia hallyday je vous confirme
que bernard montiel et un [ __ ]
est ce que vous voulez savoir ce qu'a
dit carla bonjour c'est carla bruni je
tenais à vous dire que bernard montiel
est un [ __ ] brigitte macro à oui ça me
ferait plaisir regardez
bonjour c'est brigitte macron je connais
très bien bernard montiel et c'est un
gros [ __ ] les états unis quel est ce
un message pour vous c'est le président
joe biden regarder je connais très très
bien à just say no 1 mondial c'est un
sou soeur on a une énorme stations
connaissent olivier les bolides et à se
regarder bonjour c'est olivier de
carglass
une fois j'ai changé le pare-brise de
bernard montiel et je peux vous le dire
c'est un [ __ ] ma collection
je voulais revenir sur la moquette
revenir sur ce qu'il a des gens là
mondiale qui avait duré 10 mois mais ça
va pas être rigolo parce que moi c'est
un message d'amour que je voudrais
passer hier contrairement à hier c'était
pour rigoler nanar moi c'était vraiment
pour rire et justement ce que le black
lips que je t'ai dit hier par message
parce que je t'ai appelé parce que ça me
connaît au coeur parce que j'ai vu que
tu étais blessé
et s'il n'y avait pas eu gens me sera et
tétouan en fait vous êtes mes deux pour
moi mais deux tontons que vous êtes ma
famille clairement eu et je me répète
ray toute ma vie pour moi vous êtes dans
mon coeur et donc du coup comme jean
mais n'étaient pas là c'est tombé sur
toi parce que je pensais qu'on était
assez proches pour pouvoir rigoler de ça
mais comme j'étais blessé je voulais
juste te dire que je t'aime sincèrement
et que pour moi tu étais vraiment comme
matcher
c'est mignon cg plaisir bernard aubin
bien sûr j'adore kelly et ça m'avait
blessé parce qu'elle l'a dit une
certaine façon je me j'étais surpris
j'étais triste hier soir c'est vrai nom
les autres on connaît pas ce qu on se
chambre tout le temps se taquinent tout
le temps c'est l'un des nôtres qui
veulent revenir gilbert là dessus que
vous regrettez ce que vous avez dit oui
je voudrais faire des excuses parce que
franchement bernard montel pour moi y'a
deux énormes point positif les points
positifs ce qu'il est là cinq fois par
ce mal et non le point positif c'est que
vous lui donnez jamais la parole j'en
dirai pas plus qui peut revenir aussi
sur ce qu'il a dit hier guillaume genton
non mais bien à long terme à tous que
c'est un des chroniqueurs les plus
drôles on lui doit comme des séquences
cultes de tpm pays les faits une
séquence très drôle avec boubacar x qui
était très drôle c'est peut-être content
de voir booba soit oui très j'aime
beaucoup à battre et j'ai même vu son
dernier clip qui est sorti aujourd'hui à
16 heures à pas sûrs est faible ça non
j'ai un ordinateur il ya été génial et
donc ouais non et après sur les sujets
d'actu c'est vrai que c'est son point de
vue il est un peu attendu il défend
toujours le gouvernement donc c'est vrai
qu'il a un côté un peu fou non j'ai
attaqué bachelot l'autre sur mac est
sali pendant moi je me branche pas ben
et moi on est comme les cinq de damas on
est vraiment unique comme ça il n'en
reste pas moins que c'est ce que j'aime
chez chez bernard montiel c'est son côté
un peu juste un peu dandy il est
toujours un peu décalé j'adore ces
fiches tout ça et moi j'ai beaucoup de
chance d'être tracée à droite parce que
je le kindle pendant toute l'émission
parce qu'on a plein de sourires moi je
vous la donne bon après c'est vrai c'est
quand même un gros succès
mais c'est dingue vous avez comme ça oui
moi je vous dis moi je suis fan de vous
je suis très heureux fassiez partie de
l'équipe non mais c'est vrai parce que
l'année dernière je faisais les
personnages sont justes et vraies et j y
avais benjamin tout ça qui est un peu
voilà il ya nicolas pernikoff
spécialiste de télé et chercher un
[ __ ] mois propos tu sais vous savez
qu'il a failli donc mon pécho il ya 30
ans quoi donc je vous remercie et oui à
39,6 donc il se trouvait ce serait
mignonne mais pas assez connu dans la
foire et non et maintenant c'est la mère
qui me trouble le plus c'est vrai elle
m'a interviewé au début il ya trente et
ya plus de trente ans ma main oui je la
trouve elle était sexy mignonne rigolote
toujours la poitrine à l'air c'est en
tout cas ce qu'elle pouvait et isabelle
vous n'oubliez pas de sortir avec ses
amis sa retenue surtout d'accord merci
mais n'a pas dit oui alors moi je
respecte son âge et puis surtout ce que
j'aime avec bernard sait qu'on a un
amour inconditionnel
oui on a un amour inconditionnel par
rapport aux animaux mais tu es comme les
chevaux abc tu l'as dis merci en tout
cas